[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books in more than
700,000 words the Bible can generate a
lot of questions if you'd like answers
to your Bible questions you've come to
the right place now here's your host
Pastor Doug Bachelor president and
Speaker of amazing
facts hello listening friends would you
like to hear an amazing fact back in
1942 a British Forest guard in rupan
India while patrolling 16,000 ft up in
the Himalaya Mountains made a shocking
Discovery there at the bottom of a small
Valley was a frozen lake absolutely full
of human skeletons during that warm
sunmer the ice melted revealing even
more skeletal remains floating in the
water and lying half Hazard around the
edges of the lake obviously something
horrible had happened here was it a war
Landslide Avalanche mass suicide plague
for years no one knew what had caused
this Carnage however in 2004 an
expedition to the site seems to have
finally settled the mystery of what
caused those people's deaths even though
many of the Bones still had flesh and
hair it turns out after testing the
skeletons were over a thousand years old
the cold dry climate helped preserve the
s all the bodies had evidently died in a
similar way from blows To The Head and
the shoulders as if all the blows had
come from directly above Rings Spears
leather shoes and bamboo staves were
found leading the experts to believe
that the group was comprised of pilgrims
heading through the valley with the help
of some local guides that's because the
DNA testing indicated 70% of the victims
were related to Iran and the remainder
of the ancestors the local Indian
population after much rech SE Arch the
2004 Expedition came to the same
conclusion all 300 people died in about
850 ad because they were caught
unprotected in the open by a sudden
severe and violent hail
storm this is not very hard to believe
when you consider 92 people were killed
in Bangladesh in 1986 by a hail storm
that contains Stones weighing up to a
pound and a half you know the Bible
talks about a plague where hundreds of
people were killed by Giant hillstones
stay with us friends we're going to
learn more as amazing facts brings you
this edition of Bible answers
[Music]
live you're listening to Bible answers
live honest answers to your Bible
questions our phone lines are now open
if you have a Bible related question
call us at 1 1800 God says that's 1 1800
46372 97 now now let's join our host
Pastor Doug Bachelor and our co-host
Pastor Jean Ross welcome listening
friends to Bible answers live and you've
joined a live International interactive
Bible study and if you've got a Bible
question we've got several lines open
now is the best time to give a call with
your Bible question it's a free phone
call 800 God says that's 8004
63729 maybe you weren't ready I'll give
it to you right right now one more time
7297 and I'm Doug Bachelor my name is
John Ross good evening listening friends
and Pastor Doug let's begin the program
with the word of prayer dear father in
Heaven what a privilege to be able to
study the Bible together and once again
we ask for you to guide our discussion
and our study lead us into a clear
understanding of Bible truth before we
ask us in Jesus name amen amen Pastor I
you open the program by talking about
this uh this group of people traveling
that ended up being killed as a result
of giant hailstones just coming down
upon them and it doesn't sound like
there was a cave nearby that they could
run into or something that they could
cover themselves with and they were just
there they were just being hammered by
this hail and kind of sad but every now
and again on the news you'll hear about
some big storm somewhere and uh
tremendous hail and they'll have
pictures of hail about the size of an
orange or sometimes golf ball that's
more typical but whenever you get big
chunks of hail it's quite something yeah
I think I went online as I prepared for
this amazing fact and saw that the
record G the Guinness record for the
largest hail stone in the world is
actually in America I think it was North
Dakota and it was like 8 inches around H
once someone captured it froze it they
measured it so that gets pretty big and
if you're out unprotected and you're
getting pounded by something that big it
will break your skull and uh it it can
be lethal and the Bible talks about some
hail storms like this of course one of
the plagues that fell on the Egyptians
when they continued in their rebelling
you can find in Exodus 9 it says there
was hail and this is Exodus 9:24 there
was hail and flashing fire continually
in the midst of the hail very heavy hail
such as had never been in the land of
Egypt since it became a nation the hail
struck down everything that was in the
field in all the land of Egypt both man
and Beast
and the hail struck down every plant in
the field and broke every tree of the
field that must have been some big hail
storms it's like cannon balls raining
from the sky and then when the children
of Israel were entering the promised
land and they were involved in a battle
with some of the Canaanites it says as
they fled before Israel while they were
going down the ascent of Beth horin the
Lord threw down large stones from Heaven
on them as far as ezeka and they died
and there were more who dial because of
the ha hail stor hailstones then were
killed by the soldiers of Israel and of
course this also is an echo of something
the Bible says is coming in the last
days that tells us in the Book of
Revelation that there's going to be a
tremendous hail storm connected with the
destruction at the Lord's second coming
and some of these hailstones are going
to weigh about a talent now Talent is
anywhere between 52 and 70 lbs they all
argue about whether it was the uh an
Egyptian talent and the Israeli
Babylonian Talent they all kind of had a
different scale but um anyway you don't
want to get hit by a 50 PB block of ice
you and I were talking just before we
went on the air that uh I think the
largest Hailstone North America weighed
and it's the record weighed about 1.8
pounds and it was like I think 8 Ines
around or something but um people might
want to know how do you get get ready
where do you run and hide these people
in that pilgrimage group all had nowhere
to hide in that Valley they were just
trapped in this Himalayan hail where do
you hide from 50 PB hailstones in the
last days Bible tells us the only place
to hide is under the shadow of the
almighty and we've got a book that talks
about how to prepare for the last
days the book is called the last night
on earth talking about the second coming
of Jesus and some of the events that
ought to occur just before Jesus comes
this is the free offer this evening all
you'll have to do is call us on our
resource phone number the number is 800
6747 you can ask for the book called the
last night on Earth that number again is
800 835
6747 ask for the study guide the last
night on earth actually it's a book and
if you have a Bible question the phone
line here to the studio is 800
7297 again that's 8004
97 our first caller this evening is
Michael listening from uh well long way
away from New Finland Michael welcome to
the program hey how's it going Doug good
thanks for calling and your question uh
my question tonight would be uh are you
allowed to
remarry well is a person ever allowed to
remarry of course the Bible you know
there's different circumstances under
which people get divorced and and Jesus
has some pretty clear stipulations about
what would qualify as biblical grounds
for divorce and remarriage and you can
read about this in Matthew both chapter
5 and 19 and it says uh if a person
marries somebody who's been divorced
without biblical grounds and biblical
grounds would be uh Bible calls it
fornication or adultery breaking the
marriage vow with someone else they're
then guilty of adultery and so uh
another case in 1 Corinthians 7 if if
you are an
unbeliever and you find the Lord while
you're married you're married to someone
they're both you're both unbelievers one
of them finds the Lord and the
unbeliever abandons or divorces you
would then be free to Remar according to
Paul in 1 Corinthians 7 but if a person
doesn't have biblical reasons for the
divorce or if they've been unfaithful
and their spouse divorced them they
don't have a right to
remarry so does I don't know
that's answering specifically what
you're
asking uh yeah well specifically what I
was asking was like two Believers like
myself and if my girlfriend was a
Believer
then uh if you're one of us
divorced are we are we free to go and
get remarried or is that going against
the Bible if you're divorcing just
because you feel you've got uh you know
incompatibility those are not not
biblical grounds for divorce now you
know it it's a delicate subject and I
want to make sure everybody knows
anybody can come to the Lord it doesn't
matter what your marriage baggage might
be and if a person gets divorced without
biblical grounds the Bible never calls
that the unpardonable
sin uh but if they do it it is a sin and
um you know Jesus talked to the woman at
the well and he said you've had five
husbands obviously she had done
something wrong along the way but he
still forgave her and she found the Lord
um so I want to make that clear but let
me send you a copy we have a book I've
just written and well seems like I just
wrote it but it's probably been over a
year now it's called marriage divorce
and remarriage marriage divorce and
remarriage and it answers all these
questions and it will give you the um
uh the scriptures the
references the number to call is 8835
6747 you can ask for the book marriage
divorce and remarriage again 800 835
6747 and I believe you can also read
that book for free online at the Amazing
Facts website I'm not sure if that's
posted not there okay so call for it
we'll be happy to send it to you 800 835
6747 our next call is uh Sebastian
listening from um Florida Sebastian
welcome to the
program hey good evening Pastor R and
Pastor Doug I love your guys' show in
The Amazing fact Ministry well thank you
for calling how can we help you tonight
yeah thank you um well yeah um my
question tonight is in regards to the
Heavenly Sanctuary truth and the
Judgment um how does a person know if
they're marked righteous or
not well you know if a person has
surrendered to the Lord and they've
accepted Jesus uh and they're walking in
the will of God then you know we can
have that assurance that we're under the
blood and of course if you're if you're
under the blood and you've accepted the
Lord your name is written in the Book of
Life The Promise is um but it's really a
question of uh faith and submission to
submitting to God's Will and when you
completely surrendered your heart and
you submitting to his will you're not
you know living in Rebellion you're
his so you know we we'll never like get
a fact of what's going on in the
Heavenly records here on Earth here on
Earth we live by faith in his word and
there's promises in his word that help
us know what's happening in heaven you
know we know Jesus lives in the Heavenly
Temple to ever make intercession for us
as our high priest and uh you know as we
confess our sins and repent of our sins
he is faithful and just to forgive us
from all of our sins so if we've been
forgiven from all of our sins then uh
our names are in that book and uh we're
on the we're among the um the ones that
will be sealed by the the Holy
Spirit okay I understand thank you all
right hey thanks I appreciate your
question
Sebastian next call is Peter and Peter
is listening in Nebraska Peter welcome
to the
program hi thank you hey Peter you got
to get a little closer to your phone you
sound like you're in
Nebraska yes I'm in Nebraska can you
hear me okay now well it's faint well go
ahead ask your question and we'll do our
best to repeat it for everybody okay um
I don't know which verse it is but
there's a verse in the Bible that says
that if a
person does not forgive another person
then God also will not forgive that
person yes and wondering if you could
clarify the meaning of that verse if
that actually is
saying
that God won't forgive a human being
another human right there well there's
two places you'll find it several places
what and and uh the question Peter's
asking is does the bible say that if you
refuse to forgive someone else God will
not forgive you uh yes and no it sounds
like I'm running for office the reason I
say that is it is true that if after
we've been forgiven by the Lord we
refuse to pass on that forgiveness our
forgiveness does not stay in the Lord's
Prayer it says forgive us our debts as
we forgive those who sin against us or
forgive us our trespasses as we forgive
those who trespass against us and
there's one commentary that Jesus makes
on the Lord's Prayer and he says there
that if you will not forgive men their
trespasses then neither will your father
in Heaven forgive you and you also find
this in the parable of the UN merciful
debor that you find in uh Matthew
18 where this man who was forgiven by
the king refused to pass on the
forgiveness and the King withdrew he
revoked his forgiveness because his
servant would not pass it on to his
friends and um he ended up paying the
debt which we don't want to pay our debt
so after God is it's not God this is the
reason I said yes and no God is not
saying to us um I'll make you deal you
go forgive everybody and then I'll
forgive you because he's got to forgive
us first for us to have that in our
hearts but after he forgives us and we
experience his love he expects us to
pass it on if we do not pass it on what
happens is our
bitterness destroys the love of God in
our own hearts and we lose it so after
receiving it you need to pass it on and
uh hopefully that helps by the way Peter
I've got uh a message online that you
can watch that talks about the
unmerciful deor it's on that Parable in
Matthew 18 and I have several
illustrations there I think you'll find
it a blessing appreciate your
question by the way we do have that book
The the high cost of the Cross talks
about forgiveness all right the number
to call is 8835 6747 that is the
resource phone number and you can ask
for the book called The High Cost of the
cross again 800
6747 if you have a Bible question our
phone line here to the studio is
7297 again that's 800 463 7297 looks
like we've got three or four lines still
open our next call is Emma listening
from Illinois Emma welcome to the
program hello hi Emma how you doing I am
blessed and I enjoy your program uh I
have a question on uh
rebaptism you know
John um the Baptist baptized with
submersion and then later on when the
Christ was uh preaching they said they
and I just wondered if they people that
were baptized by John the Baptist were
re-baptized uh when they heard the
message of Christ good question um most
of them know the apostles for instance
were baptized by John the Baptist and
Jesus was baptized by John the Baptist
and when Christ began his ministry
there's no record that they had to get
re-baptized and matter of fact there was
an overlap for several years where Jesus
and John the Baptist or his disciples
after John was imprisoned were still
baptizing people who were repenting and
coming to the Lord Jesus never said that
John's baptism was not qualified but
there was one example in Acts 19 where
some disciples it talks about 12
Ephesian Believers that they had heard
the message of John they'd been baptized
and then they left and went back to Asia
before they heard about Jesus in his
ministry and they somehow just missed
out on the whole thing Paul preached
preached to them about Jesus and
re-baptized them and they were filled
with the holy spirit because there's so
much they had missed um that they were
re-baptized so that's the only case I
don't know if Pastor Ross knows of
another one the only case I know of of a
rebaptism like that in the New Testament
I think that's the one so okay then then
the other question is like when a
parents dedicate their children like and
have them baptized you know two three
four five six years old um does that
baptism I mean do they is it their
discretion to get re-baptized when they
are adults now if a person is baptized
as a child and it depends on the age you
know if a person's baptized as a baby
and they really don't know what's going
on or if they're baptized at 5 years old
and you know they really don't have
their own devotional life they don't
understand the the themes of the Gospel
they're not repenting of real Sin um
they would probably need to be baptized
AP ized biblically uh the Bible says of
course before you baptized Jesus said go
and teach All Nations they be need to be
old enough to be taught what the gospel
is they need to be able to repent of
their sins the Bible says they need to
be able to believe and if they can't
meet those
criteria then they should be re-baptized
when they're old enough to understand
those things um I I appreciate your um
understanding of that I appreciate your
program and um you've clar I some things
in my mind and and this will help me
when somebody else directs a question to
me uh about that and I really appreciate
it and God bless you well thank you for
your and we appreciate that uh your call
Emma and uh by the way we do have a book
on baptism is it necessary and it gives
you those scriptures we'll send you a
free copy the number to call is 800 835
6747 and you can just ask for the book
called baptism is it necessary the
number again is 8800 835
6747 if you have a Bible question a
phone line here to the studio this
evening is
7297 and we have Gary listening from um
looks like Michigan Gary welcome to the
program yes good evening hiy Gary is
there a Houston Michigan uh it's
Mississippi oh miss okay hey we're glad
you
called
and your question yes I have a question
on divorce as well um I I want to know
in the Bible does it not say that if a
woman leaves her husband she must remain
unmarried until his death or whatever
that she's been living in adultery I
want to know what it says about the
husband if uh the wife abandons the
marriage and leaves the marriage bed for
you know over 12 months and and um
demands no fault divorce which you know
that's what happened to me
and uh and then you go and you have a
relationship with another woman I want
to know if the Bible says anything about
um when where is adultery and when is it
forgiven or when is it not adultery when
you marry again or
um well I give you or does it desine
saying you know when someone's heart
leaves you and they no longer love you
and they you know there's no connection
anymore
there yeah you know you're you're
describing something that is it's it's
not that uncommon and it is a very
difficult situation to be in where one
of the spouses sort of abandons the
marriage while they're still in the
marriage and the other person gets so
lonely that they often develop another
relationship and or they it ends in
divorce and then the question is you
know if they go out and get remarried is
there ever a hope for Redemption are
they forever caught outside of God's
will you you've got the example in the
Bible of well a couple of examples one
would be the Samaritan woman who had
been married five times she was living
with someone she wasn't married to and
Jesus forgave her and then you've got
the example of David who did a terrible
thing in committing adultery with bath
Sheba he had no biblical grounds to take
her as his wife I mean he basically
killed her husband that's not good
biblical grounds for
remarriage but after he was punish for
his sin and he repented of his sin um
God had been calling beath Sheba UAH
wife after David repented it says David
knew his wife Beth Sheba they had
another son named Solomon who ended up
becoming King he evidently forgave them
but the the consequences of their
Disobedience stayed with David the rest
of his life um so is there
forgiveness uh generally if there's
genuine repentance there is um and it is
very difficult I don't I don't want to
undermine how lonely some people are in
bad marriages that's why you have to be
very careful when you pick who your
partner is going to be for life because
it's not something God wants us to you
just kind of jump in and out of as is so
often done these days in in particular
in Hollywood um and I'll be happy to
send you Gary a copy of our book a free
copy of the book marriage divorce and
remarriage and it's I really spent some
time on this because I wanted to answer
the most common questions and we give
you Bible
samples the number to call is 80083 5
6747 and again you can ask for the book
called marriage divorce and remarriage
if you have a Bible question our phone
line here to the studio is 800 463
7297 800
46372 97 next call is Deborah listening
from North Dakota uh Deborah welcome to
the
program hello hi Deborah thanks for
calling hi um thank you for taking my
call I had a question question on
numbers um chapter 20 okay verse
1-13 where you know there was no water
and the people were complaining and
Moses and Aaron went before the Lord and
then they go
and get water from the Rock and then
God said to Moses because you didn't
trust in me enough to honor me as holy
in the sight of Israel you'll not bring
this Community into the land I give you
so he was basically punished
severely right I don't understand that
and then I don't understand is there a
correlation to us
today yeah that that's a good question
so why was Moses punished and not
allowed to lead the people all the way
into the promised land after he' brought
them 40 years uh Moses as their leader
and as the mediator between God man and
he was even a type of Christ according
to to both his prophecy and Jesus when
God told him that uh you're to go and
speak to the Rock and you can read that
in numbers 20:8 he was to take uh the
staff and go and tell the rock before
them and it will yield water but instead
Moses and Aaron became upset and they
struck the rock twice and he said to the
people must we bring you water out of
this and and it wasn't them
that did it they didn't give God glory
and U he basically lost his temper he
says here now ye Rebels shall we bring
you water out of this rock he's sort of
taking credit like we're going to bring
water well he struck the Rock and water
came out but he wasn't supposed to
strike The Rock he was supposed to speak
to the Rock he supposed to say God has
given you the water not Moses and Aaron
and so God could have been very severe
he could have done what he did with the
sons of Aaron where they died instantly
but God said look I love you Moses I'm
going to save you but you can't be the
one that's going to lead the people into
the promised land but God did say look
I'll I'll meet you halfway he brought
him up to Mount Nebo and before Moses
died God gave him a vision a panorama
where he could look across the Jordan
with Supernatural vision and he showed
them he showed him the promised land so
it was almost like he gave him a
spiritual flyover of the land and he got
to rejoice in that and in one sense he
kind of Saved Moses the headache of of
um having to bring the people into the
promised land so he got to finally rest
you know you think about it and uh God
performed Moses funeral I mean talk
about having someone important at your
funeral it says God buried Moses and no
one knew where his grave was and so he
honored him in that way as well he the
Lord felt a very Tender Love for Moses
but he did need to set an example the
god expected obedience Moses was the
example and when Moses disobeyed uh
there was a consequence for that and um
yep 120 years old anyway hope that helps
a little bit Deborah we appreciate your
question and I was just trying to think
you know we do have that um study guide
that talks about written in stone talks
about the law and um I've got a group of
s uh sermons online Deborah that deal
with the subject of Christ and the types
of Moses is a type of Christ in the
Bible you can find it's Jesus in all the
Bible and you go to the Amazing Facts
website you'll see that there Jesus and
all of the Bible and for our friends
that are listening we just going to take
a uh a break at the bottom of our
program and um you can also go to the
website a lot of the resources that we
send people for free you just go to
amazingfacts.org and you'll see them
there uh if you have Bible questions we
still have some lines open pick up a
phone give us a call that's 800
N7
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return in a
moment amazing facts began in
1965 with a god inspired concept hello
this is Joe Cruz on the amazing facts
broadcast facts which affect you each
radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every Walk of Life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of Television to its growing Outreach
efforts offering Soul winning
Evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world in 1994 Pastor Doug Bachelor
assume leadership of the ministry adding
the Bible answers live call-in radio
program and new ministry TV programs
began airing on multiple networks around
the world for 50 years the driving
vision of amazing facts has been the
Bold proclamation of the Everlasting
gospel and with a team of evangelists
circling the globe and thousands of men
and women being trained through the
amazing fact Center of evangelism
program AFCO the min is helping God's
Church see a Rich Harvest of
souls amazing facts God's message our
[Music]
mission every Bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers
live we still have a few phone lines
open if you have a Bible related
question call us at 1 1800 God says
that's 1 1800
46372 N7 now let's join pastors Doug
Bachelor and Jean Ross for more Bible
answers
live welcome back listening friends if
you join somewhere along the way this is
Bible answers live and you can call in
with your Bible questions one more time
it's 8800 463
7297 and uh Pastor Ross and I I think
are about ready to go back to the phones
we have Ry who is listening in Michigan
Ray welcome to the program Ray in
Michigan hello sir how you do you both
are doing a very good job tonight thank
you for your
patience yeah um I have a question if
uh in the beginning there it was just
God the Father God the son and God the
Holy Spirit and and before he started
Crea everything and he he
knew he he knows he's he's a he's Alpha
and Omega he knows the beginning and the
end right he KN and he knew that the
human race would uh Rebel and go against
some I knew that Jesus Christ would have
to come to Earth and die die on the
cross
why why would he and we need God more
than he needs us why would he even
created the human race and all right
that's yeah you're asking really the big
question which is if if God is love and
if he's all powerful and if he's all
knowing and he knew that this rebellion
was going to happen why would he make
the human race or why did he make
Lucifer this angel that turned into a
devil did did God not know that that
this devil would go bad this Angel would
turn into a devil um this is the
greatest demonstration that God makes
his creatures free and intelligent is
that he will make a creature that will
even choose not to love him and so God
went ahead and he made these creatures
and he made them free and they really
did have a choice Lucifer chose to love
himself more and he became proud and the
more he nurtured his pride it just got
worse until he became so self-centered
he rebelled against God brought his
Rebellion to our planet and our first
parents followed in his footsteps and
and now this Spirit of rebellion and sin
has spread to all the creatures there's
really two motives in the world one is
love and one is selfishness God is love
the devil is selfish and um God you know
loving parents will have kids they never
know if the kids are going to obey or
turn out difficult and God they still
have the children and so God is a loving
father and he had these children he
wants to redeem as many as will be
redeemed and that's why he sent his son
and so you know we have a DVD that you
know people can they can ask for the DVD
but we also have it free online now it's
called Cosmic conflict you just type in
the words Cosmic conflict and go to
YouTube I think you can probably watch
it in several languages now uh people
have uploaded the DVD and so it's there
but it explains why there is sin and why
did God go ahead and make the world in
spite of the fact that um he knows all
things and I think you'll find
encouragement in that Ray thank you for
your question and uh appreciate your
call our next call is Phil listening
from New York Phil welcome to the
program C could you hear me okay loud
and clear Phil great thank you for
taking my call my question is this I'm
reading in the papers that the combined
Russian Iranian and Syrian government
forces have just about destroyed all
organized opposition so my question is
are we seeing biblical prophecy in
today's newspapers is this the beginning
of the war of Gog and
MOG well you've asked a question and I'd
have to say yes and no again yes are we
seeing prophecy fulfilled in the papers
I do believe we are but I would disagree
that Russia is Gog and Magog uh that's a
a popular teaching that was circul it I
think it may have start started in the
scoffield Bible before that most people
didn't identify Russia as Gog or MOG um
and from Scofield's Bible how Lindsay
repeated that and it became a very
popular uh teaching among charismatic
Christians and and is gone from there
but the uh the old Protestants believe
Gog and Magog if you you first find go
and Magog in I think Genesis 10 they
represent the enemies of God's people in
the old Testament it's repeated in
Ezekiel I think 37 it talks about is
that right Pastor Ross 37 talks about
Gog and Magog yeah and um and even in 38
as well um so when you get to Revelation
20 and it says the wicked cover the
Earth Gog and
Magog um Gog was the enemy of God's
people Magog means from The Matrix or
the children of go and in ba in
Revelation you got Babylon and her
daughters the children of Babylon and so
um it's just talking about the wicked
and the children of the wicked in the
context of a of a final showdown in
God's Deliverance in the historical
situation you have the children of
Israel who were uh being pressed on
either side by their enemies and um God
came to the Deliverance so likewise in
the Book of Revelation you have this
final showdown between the forces of of
good uh God's people and then the wicked
rising up against them and God comes to
their
Deliverance but the the Russian Iranian
Alliance is not uh so closely associated
with it as most people believe is that
the case yeah I I think that I think
some Sinister things are happening right
there in the Middle East there there is
a a clamoring for control of that
territory I think personally I think
that America has lost ground while
Russia was you know um occupying the
Crimea giving them another naval base in
the Mediterranean and what they're doing
in Syria and kind of a coalition between
Syria and Iran I think some very
Sinister things are happening that
they're looking to consolidate power
there but I'm not sure that that's
pointing to Gog and MOG okay I I
understand you exactly and you really
clarified something and that is as you
indicated a popular
misconception and I I'm pretty much
disabused of it at present so I do thank
you for your excellence and thank you
very much sir thank you Phil appreciate
your call our next call is uh Edwin and
he's listening in Texas Edwin welcome to
the
program hello there it's uh it's Edward
here Edward hi that's my name my name's
Douglas Edwards so I should know that
all right Edward yeah how's your what's
your question tonight oh hey Pastor Doug
it's great to actually you know be
talking to you um likewise but my
question my question tonight would be
well let me just give you I guess a
little uh little bit of information
before because I'm I'm 16 years old but
you know I see my friends they have all
these things that they do and I go to a
charter school which is four hours a day
and pretty much I have time on my hand a
lot of the time and I catch myself
watching way too many uh way too many of
your sermons Pastor Doug and uh so but
that's not a bad thing I know that's not
a bad thing and um I'm well I've got
mixed feelings but I'm glad you're
watching yes sure um but I was basically
my question would be I've been because
I've been avoiding working out and
spending time in the gym because of
my experience with that I've used to be
very much into bodybuilding M and and
you know I've I've grown up with really
a good physique a muscular a good
muscular build as I've been growing up
but lately I've been for the past two
years I've kind of neglected it ever
since I've been trying to
uh um you know ever since I became like
a baby Christian and all these things I
just been neglecting I didn't want to
fall into Pride or selfishness and you
know so I guess my question would be how
much time should
should a Christian or you know yeah I
guess a Christian would how much time
should a Christian spend in the gym a
good questioning weights well you know
there's certainly nothing wrong with
exercise and I you know I was at the gym
today uh playing a few games of
racketball about 7 o'clock this morning
and it just wakes you up makes you feel
good uh it you know virtually all people
if they're honest have a certain amount
of consciousness of their health and
their body um everyone's looked ATS in
the mirror you don't want to become vain
where you're preoccupied with that it
turns into self worship there's nothing
wrong with exercising and you might
wonder am I gaining any strength and you
look in the mirror and say oh it looks
like I'm filling out that's a good thing
but you know it it's like someone said
perfume is for sniffing not for
swallowing and so being aware that your
health is improving or that you need to
lose weight or you are losing weight
whatever the the question might that's
that's good there's it's important to be
heal aware of your body your health you
don't want to become uh you know where
you're preoccupied with it and you're
you know read the muscle magazines and
and uh flexing in the
mirror yeah so there's a balance there
you know what my issue is when I go to
the gym I can't wait to get inside the
racket ball court because just walking
through the gym the way people dress is
never very modest and then the music
they play is it's just it's always just
kind of a pounding exercise music and uh
I don't care much for that but um
there's certainly nothing wrong with
being an exercise programmer using
weights so you got to have a a balance
and moderation in that area does that
make
sense yeah sir but I guess we to clarify
that really is individually because some
of my friends uh from church oh I'm 16
and it's kind of weird calling them
friends but they're like 30 years old or
20 they spend they spend time like 30
minutes in the gym or so but should that
be should that be like an individual
thing or should should I you know I
guess should I keep track of my time
because they say they say 30 minutes
would be good you know 30 45 minutes
would be good and more than that I guess
i' be not bad but you don't want to
spend too much time because then you
you'll be outside of or you might not
find time for God right things like that
well I you know I wouldn't tell you what
the time would be I I think it's it's
okay to you know schedule some time in
the gym it might be 30 minutes it might
be an hour just whatever you need uh I I
know people that are going through
different training programs to try and
get their body in shape they'll go from
one system to another and they'll do leg
exercises and then arm exercises and
torso exercises and it might take an
hour to get through the the um the
different stations so you know just
whatever you need I I I wouldn't spend a
lot of time I tease my friends that play
golf and I think where in the world do
they get you know you know 4 hours a day
to play golf I can't I never got that
much time so that to me seems like it
goes overboard but I maybe when I retire
I'll change my mind Hey I appreciate
your call Edward and uh you stay close
to the Lord keep listening to the right
kind of videos God bless you our next
call is Julie listening in California
Upland Julie welcome to the program hi
good evening Pastor Doug yeah and Pastor
Ross hello
was there a pastor Ross there too yes
this is he I think he's person hi you
anyway I I have to I have to say that I
find myself watching too many Doug
Bachelor sermons myself and I really
like the one on your addiction to ice
cream oh cold
confession that was a good one and but
especially right now I'm loving the ones
unlock but my question to you is earlier
today you put on something about where
we are in Earth's history and you went
through the pope and
um like what we've been expecting to
happen is going to happen so I a little
bit more was that a video that you saw
on the computer on YouTube yes yeah we
just posted that oh I think Friday so
it's only been up uh it's got yeah
several thousand views it's been up for
a couple days I was talking about Islam
and prophecy and you know the King of
the North and Daniel 11 right yeah if if
people want to see that video I think
it's called Uh Islam and Christianity in
Prophecy oh do you have it it's in a
YouTube yeah you can just watch it on
YouTube and if you go to your computer
just type in Christianity Islam Doug
Bachelor it'll probably bring it up on
YouTube okay great and everyone can
watch it for free so do you do you have
any approximate time no we don't know
when these things are going to happen
I'm I'm very careful not to set dates
but I do see that it seems like there is
a
consolidating of um Christianity and
Islam seem to be polarizing right now in
the world and and you know I would have
thought it would have
been Catholicism well Christianity it
Catholicism is you know of course the
leading group in Christianity well I
don't consider them Christians because
of what I think of the Pope and what
tending to be you know I'm sure there
are a lot of Catholics that are very
sincere in their belief of Christ I
would respectfully disagree with some of
the conclusions that uh Roman Catholics
have about um the forgiveness of sin
confessing to priests praying to Mary
you know some of that uh to me is
violation of the Ten Commandments and
idolatry and so forth but I got to be
careful you you know you don't want to
judge and say that you know no
Christians or no Catholics are
Christians so when I talk about the
Christians of the world I'm talking
about statistics I'm not talking about
really what the Bible says uh of the two
major world religions there are about
1.7 billion Muslims and there's 2.2
billion Christians that includes
Catholics evangelicals charismatic
Protestant the whole thing together so
among the major religions of the world
they fall under the banners of one under
Christianity being the largest there's
many branches of that including
Catholicism and the other under Islam
and there are several branches of
Islam but it seems like these religions
are polarizing and I I was speculating
that Daniel 11 in the last days this may
be talking about the King of the North
the king in the South so you know I
don't know all the answers but it's
looking like it's shaping up that way
anyway take a look at that Julie and I
don't know why we were getting some
feedback when you and I talked at the
same time um and uh just go to YouTube
and look at that prophecy Christianity
I'm sorry Islam Christianity and
prophecy thank you appreciate your call
we have Joseph listening from New York
New York Joseph welcome to the program
hi how you doing I'm sorry about that um
yeah my call my Call is about um
Christmas and how um how knowing the how
we knowing that um the Messiah wasn't
born in that time or this time are are
we allowed to um sanctify a pagan
ritual well let you this is always we
get this question this time of year and
it's a good question um everyone most
Bible students recognize that uh it's
pretty clear Jesus was not born the
December 31 or 25 date um the reasons
being three main reasons one is it tells
us that Jesus ministered for 3 and 1/2
years from his birthday he was baptized
on his 30th birthday that's Luke chapter
3 uh so we know when he died he died in
Passover that's spring you subtract
three and a half years that puts the
birth of Christ in the fall U
furthermore the Shepherds were in their
fields and with the climate in Bethlehem
the Shepherds would never be in their
fields the 25th of December and the
Caesar Augustus would never issue a
everyone to travel for a census in the
middle of winter when there's no food in
the fields
so it's pretty certain Christ was born
in the fall we don't know the date and
it is also pretty certain that the date
of the 25th of December it comes to us
from a pagan Roman Holiday mithraism In
Rome they celebrated the day uh of of
worshiping the birth of the sun on the
25th of December because the shortest
day of the year in the northern
hemisphere is the 21st of dece of
December the days are not noticeably
longer until the 25th it became a
holiday among many Pagan countries the
Christians adopted that date trying to
reach pagans as the date of Christ's
birthday now what do you do after you
know that as a Christian well for one
thing i' just say be educated if if
you're going to celebrate the birth of
Christ let people know that you're
thankful that God gave his son since
we're not certain on the date we're
going to go ahead and buy into the the
date well I would say Buy in is the
wrong phrase but we'll go ahead and
participate in Remembering his birth
during this time of year it always seems
strange if you're can like celebrate the
birth of Jesus in July but you know if
I'm ever preaching about the wise men in
February just seems odd anyway um and
there's nothing wrong with Christians
exchanging gifts you know God is a the
biggest Giver so in in theory there's
nothing wrong with the principle uh I
think Christians ought to stay away from
the Santa Claus U tide log and the kind
of the
Pagan aspects and trappings of
Christianity sanctify it no I'm not
saying we sanctify anything I'm just
saying that there's nothing wrong with
Christians exchanging gifts and
remembering Christ's birth because
that's all in the Bible you read in
Matthew chapter one is it okay we do it
on the 25th yeah I why not since we
don't know the day so so yes so your
answer is yes we can stify it let me
give you Romans
14 Romans 14 says one man regards one
day above another another man regards
every day alike Let each man be
persuaded in his own mind if you're
going to regard the day regard it to the
Lord and if you don't regard the day you
don't no one's required to do it if
you're going to do it do it to the
Lord so hey hopefully that helps a
little bit and appreciate your question
Joseph we do have a book called baptize
paganism and I think that it'll shed a
little more light on that for you we'll
be happy to send you a free copy the
number to call is 800
83567 47 you can ask for the book called
baptized paganism again 800 835
6747 our next call is Kesha listening
from Troy Michigan Kesha welcome to the
program Hi how are you good thank you
for calling yes thank you for having me
um so my question is surrounded uh
behind a backstory is very quick um
basically I was listening to another
station um and the program was similar
to this one and a young man asked the
question where um did Jesus go after he
died on the cross um and I know that he
was with um two criminals and he said um
I'll you'll be with me in Paradise on
the other side um so long story short
the Pastor said when Jesus died on the
cross he went immediately to be with his
father in Heaven and the thief next to
him went with him and then three days
later he rose with his glorified body
and then once he ascended he went back
up um so my question is where did he go
after the crucifixion I've heard things
about Abraham's bosom
um yeah I let me let me jump in and try
and help you with that a little bit
first of all I'd have to respectfully
disagree with any Pastor that said after
Jesus died on the cross he immediately
went to the father's presence they're
not reading the whole Bible hear that
yeah you just you go to John chapter 21
and when Mary is at the tomb she goes to
grab Jesus by the feet and worship in
and Jesus says don't touch me I think
the new King James says do not detain me
because I have not yet ascended to my
father that's Sunday morning so when
Jesus died on the cross the Bible's
really clear he
died and he didn't go anywhere the Bible
has no record of Jesus you know going
and appearing to anybody when Christ
died he was dead until he rose Sunday
morning doesn't say he went to the
father now what Jesus said to the thief
that confuses people this is in Luke
chapter 23 I think Pastor Ross
um on am I getting that right yeah I
think it's Luke 23 he said to the thief
um verily I say to you today you will be
with me in Paradise now the emphasis is
I'm telling you today you will be with
me in Paradise he's not saying you will
be with me in Paradise today he said I'm
making a promise today even though I
don't look like a king and I don't look
like a Lord I'm promising you Paradise
so the emphasis is I'm making a promise
today he's not saying today you and I
are going to Paradise because a day in
the Bible doesn't even begin and end
until sundown now Jesus died before
Sundown but they had to break the
thieves legs because they wanted them to
die before Sundown and they weren't dead
yet okay does that make sense yes and
then so the second part of the question
is where do we go until the second
coming do we just fall into asleep or
yeah well the Bible actually tells us
Jesus said when Lazarus died he said our
friend Lazarus is asleep and I go and
wake him and the disciples said oh if
he's sleeping maybe he'll get better and
Jesus said no Lazarus is dead so Jesus
called death asleep and after he rose
Lazarus after being dead 4 days Lazarus
did not come back to life and say oh
Lord I was up in heaven why'd you bring
me back and he didn't say I was in
Abraham bosom he didn't say I was in
hell in fact there are about a dozen
resurrections in the entire Bible no one
who's resurrected ever comments on being
anywhere they were all asleep and so um
it doesn't seem like that for the saved
when they die you know just one more
thought on this verse that we're talking
about here in Luke
23:43 what a lot of people Miss is the
question that the thief asked Jesus in
verse 42 he said Lord remember me when
you come in your kingdom so the thief
wasn't expecting to receive his reward
right away he was looking to a future
event and said remember me when you come
again when you come in your kingdom so
um just an important point to remember
when studying that verse is to look at
the context yep hey kha you know we
would like to give you a copy of our
study guide that just makes it very
clear on the subject of death it's
called are the Dead really dead we'll
send you a free copy the number to call
is 8835 6747 you can ask for the study
guide called are the Dead really dead
our next call is uh Joe listening from
Eugene Oregon Hey Joe we've got about a
minute and a half can we get a question
in of course
sir and you're you're
on okay well I was when I read your book
the richest cavan great story uh thank
you for that so I was wondering how did
you having no educational necessarily
educational background first pick up the
the Bible in the cave and then read it
and understand and comprehend it so I'm
starting to read it I'm a junior in
college and I don't necessarily
understand a whole lot of it um that's
why I rely on your videos and going to
church and stuff for the for the
clarifications I was just wondering how
you do it sir well uh for one thing I
didn't understand it all when I first
picked it up I was you know 17 years old
and a lot of things I didn't understand
in my book I think I mentioned that I I
had some real wild misconceptions about
the Bible but you keep reading and you
get better and I read some I read some
great commentaries uh you know one of
the best things I ever read that helped
me understand the Bible was a book
called Patriarchs and Prophets and I
read it along with the Bible and um I
don't know if you've heard of that book
but it's just a classic you just type in
Patriarchs and Prophets I think you can
probably read it for free online because
it was written in oh around the turn of
the last century but um and and so
getting some good inspired commentaries
that'll make it pretty clear for you uh
you know Joe we do have a um we've got a
lesson we can send you a free copy
actually the book that we wrote called
the ultimate resource it talks about the
Bible and how to study the Bible and I
think you'll enjoy that and stay at it
it's like learning any new thing
learning a new language it takes a
little time time to study hey friends I
apologize I don't think we've got time
for another question at least not to do
it justice but God willing we're going
to be back again next week doing more
Bible questions some of you hear these
programs reruns and we may be back in 3
hours doing more Bible questions
whichever it is we're just so glad to
study with you keep in mind especially
this time of year we are a nonprofit
organization the only thing that keeps
us on the air it's people like you who
are listening that say Hey I like this
program I want it to stay on on this
station you can send a donation online
to
amazingfacts.org just click the link
that says con uh donate and uh we do
appreciate it God bless we'll talk again
next
[Music]
week thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts a faith-based Ministry located in
Sacramento
California are you wondering what lies
ahead in human history landmarks of
Prophecy offers clear answers to your
most pressing questions presented by
Pastor Doug Bachelor landmarks of
Prophecy is a video Bible study
Adventure designed for today's audiences
presenting The Landmark themes of the
Bible in a compelling way giving you
knowledge to face the future with
confidence start your epic Bible study
adventure with landmarks of Prophecy
today by calling 8005382583
[Music]
in Journey get yours today by calling
8005382583
[Music]
get your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at 800 835
6747 or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible
questions